Merci ! C'est vraiment un honneur et un privilège d'être ici
pour passer mon dernier jour d'adolescente.
Aujourd'hui je veux vous parler du futur, mais
d'abord je vais faire un petit détour par le passé.
Mon histoire commence bien avant ma naissance.
Ma grand-mère était dans un train pour Auschwitz, le camp d'extermination.
Et elle suivait les rails, et soudain les rails se divisèrent.
Et d'une certaine façon -- nous n'avons jamais connu toute l'histoire --
le train a été mal aiguillé et s'est dirigé vers un camp de travail plutôt que vers Auschwitz.
Ma grand-mère a survécu et s'est mariée à mon grand-père.
Ils ont vécu en Hongrie, où ma mère est née.
Et lorsque ma mère eut 2 ans, alors que la révolution
faisait rage, mes grands-parents décidèrent de fuir la Hongrie.
Il prirent un bateau, qui fut l'occasion d'une autre divergence --
le bateau partait soit pour le Canada, soit pour l'Australie.
Ils montèrent sans savoir où ils débarqueraient, et sont finalement arrivés au Canada.
En résumé, mes grands-parents ont émigré au Canada.
Ma grand-mère était chimiste. Elle a travaillé au Banting Institute à Toronto,
et mourut à 44 ans d'un cancer de l'estomac. Je ne l'ai jamais connue,
mais je porte son nom -- à l'identique, Eva Vertes --
and j'aime à penser que je porte aussi sa passion scientifique.
J'ai découvert cette passion près d'ici, en fait, lorsque j'avais 9 ans.
Nous passions des vacances familiales itinérantes, et nous étions au Grand Canyon.
Et je n'ai jamais été une lectrice pendant ma jeunesse --
mon père avait essayé de me faire lire les "Frères Hardy", j'avais essayé Nancy Drew,
j'avais essayé tout ça -- mais je n'aimais pas la lecture.
Ma mère a alors acheté ce livre quand nous étions au Grand Canyon, qui
s'appelait "Virus." Il traitait de l'épidémie du virus Ebola.
Et quelque chose m'a juste attiré vers ce livre.
Il y avait cette espèce de virus cabossé sur la couverture,
et j'ai juste eu envie de le lire. J'ai pris le livre,
et tandis que nous quittions le Grand Canyon
pour nous diriger vers Big Sur [partie Sud de la côté californienne] et vers ici-même, Monterey,
j'ai lu ce livre, et à partir de cette lecture initiale,
j'ai su que je voulais consacrer ma vie à la médecine.
Je voulais être comme ces explorateurs dont parlait ce livre,
qui partaient dans les jungles africaines,
revenaient dans leurs labos de recherche et tentaient de comprendre
la nature de ce virus mortel. A partir de ce moment, j'ai lu tous les livres
médicaux sur lesquels je pouvais tomber, et cela m'a tellement plu.
J'étais alors une observatrice passive du monde médical.
Ce n'est qu'en entrant au lycée que j'ai pensé,
"Peut-être que maintenant -- en tant qu'étudiante au lycée --
je peux devenir partie prenante dans ce grand monde médical."
J'avais 14 ans, et j'ai envoyé des e-mails aux professeurs de l'université locale
pour savoir si je pouvais travailler dans leurs labos. Personne n'a répondu.
Mais après tout, pourquoi répondre à une jeune fille de 14 ans ?
Puis je suis allée discuter avec un professeur, le Dr Jacobs,
qui m'a acceptée dans son laboratoire.
À cette époque, j'étais très intéressée par les neurosciences
et je voulais faire un projet de recherche en neurologie
-- spécifiquement sur les effets des métaux lourds sur le développement du système nerveux.
J'ai débuté ce projet, et j'ai travaillé dans le laboratoire pendant un an,
pour trouver des résultats que tout un chacun s'attendrait à trouver
si vous donnez des métaux lourds à des drosophiles -- cela endommage très sérieusement le système nerveux.
La moelle épinière était fragmentée, les neurones se croisaient dans tous les sens.
À parti de ces résultats, j'ai voulu regarder non pas la dégradation, mais sa prévention.
C'est ce qui m'a menée à la maladie d'Alzheimer. J'ai commencé à lire sur la maladie d'Alzheimer
et j'ai essayé de me familiariser avec la recherche menée sur ce sujet,
et en même temps j'étais dans le --
Un jour j'étais dans la bibliothèque médicale, et j'ai lu cet article
qui traitait des dérivés de la purine.
Ces dérivés semblaient capables de favoriser la croissance cellulaire.
Comme j'étais naïve sur le sujet, j'ai pensé
"Oh, il y a mort cellulaire dans la maladie d'Alzheimer
qui cause une perte de mémoire, et il y a ces produits
-- les dérivés de la purine -- qui promeuvent la croissance cellulaire."
Donc j'ai pensé, "Peut-être si cela peut promouvoir la croissance cellulaire,
cela peut également inhiber la mort cellulaire."
Et c'est ce projet que j'ai poursuivi pendant cette année,
qui continue encore aujourd'hui,
et qui a trouvé qu'un dérivé particulier de la purine, nommé guanidine
inhibait le développement cellulaire d'environ 60%.
J'ai présenté ces résultats lors de l'International Science Fair [concours de recherches indépendantes pré-universitaires]
qui fut l'une des plus extraordinaires expériences de ma vie.
J'ai alors été récompensée par le Prix de Meilleure Recherche en Médecine
ce qui m'a permis d'entrer, ou au moins de mettre un pied dans la porte du monde médical.
Dès lors que je faisais partie de cet immense et excitant environnement,
j'ai voulu tout explorer. Je voulais tout d'un coup, mais je savais que je ne pourrais l'obtenir.
Et je suis tombée sur quelque chose appelé cellules souches cancéreuses.
Et c'est le véritable sujet de ma conférence aujourd'hui -- le cancer.
Au départ lorsque j'ai entendu parler de cellules souches cancéreuses,
je ne savais pas vraiment comment assembler les deux notions. Cellules souches,
j'en avais entendu parler comme panacée de la médecine future,
la possible thérapie de nombreuses maladies actuelles et futures.
Mais je connaissais le cancer comme la maladie actuelle la plus redoutée,
alors comment assembler ces deux notions contradictoires ?
L'été dernier j'ai travaillé à l'Université de Stanford, sur les cellules souches cancéreuses.
Et en parallèle, j'explorais la littérature sur le cancer,
en essayant -- encore -- de me familiariser avec ce nouveau domaine médical.
Et il semblait que les tumeurs se formaient à partir d'une cellule souche.
Cela m'a fascinée. Plus je lisais, et plus je considérais le cancer différemment,
moins je le craignais, en quelque sorte.
Le cancer est apparemment le résultat direct d'une blessure du corps.
Si vous fumez, vous endommagez votre tissu pulmonaire, et le cancer du poumon se développe.
Si vous buvez, vous abimez votre foie, et le cancer du foie se développe.
C'était très intéressant -- certains articles faisaient la corrélation
entre les fractures osseuses et le risque de développement de cancer osseux.
Parce que la nature des cellules souches -- ce sont
ces cellules fantastiques qui ont la possibilité de devenir
n'importe quel type de tissu.
Donc, si le corps réalise qu'un organe est endommagé et qu'il débute le
processus de cancérisation, c'est presque comme s'il s'agissait d'une réparation.
Et le corps voit que le tissu pulmonaire est endommagé, et dit
il faut réparer le poumon. Et le cancer débute dans ce poumon
qui essaie de se réparer -- car il y a cette prolifération excessive
de ces cellules remarquables qui peuvent devenir du tissu pulmonaire.
C'est presque comme si le corps avait initié cette réponse ingénieuse,
mais ne pouvait réellement la contrôler.
Cette réponse n'est pas encore assez précise pour terminer ce qu'elle a commencé.
Ces phénomènes m'ont réellement, vraiment fascinée.
et j'ai véritablement réalisé qu'on ne peut réfléchir au cancer
-- et encore moins à toute autre maladie -- en termes manichéens.
Si nous éliminons le cancer comme aujourd'hui, par chimiothérapie et radiations,
en bombardant le corps ou le cancer de toxines, ou de radiations, pour le tuer,
c'est presque comme si nous revenions au point de départ.
Nous supprimons les cellules cancéreuses, mais nous révélons alors les lésions
précédentes que le corps avait tenté de réparer.
Ne devrions-nous pas penser à manipuler, plutôt qu'à éliminer ?
Si nous trouvons un moyen de provoquer la différenciation de ces cellules,
afin qu'elles deviennent du tissu osseux, pulmonaire, hépatique,
quel que soit le tissu que le cancer est initialement supposé réparer --
il s'agirait d'un processus de réparation. Nous serions dans une meilleure situation qu'avant le cancer.
Tout ceci a vraiment changé ma façon de voir le cancer.
Et pendant que je lisais tous ces articles sur le cancer,
il me semblait qu'ils -- beaucoup d'entre eux -- se concentraient sur
l'aspect génétique du cancer du sein. Et sur la genèse
et la progression du cancer du sein --
comment repérer le cancer dans le corps, où il se trouve, où il va.
Cela m'a frappé de ne jamais avoir entendu parler de cancer du cœur,
ou d'aucun autre muscle squelettique d'ailleurs.
Les muscles squelettiques constituent 50% de notre corps,
voire plus. Et j'ai commencé à penser,
"Peut-être y a-t-il une explication évidente au fait
que le cancer ne touche pas les muscles squelettiques -- je ne la connais pas."
Donc, j'ai exploré plus avant, trouvé autant d'articles que je pouvais,
et c'était étonnant -- car il s'est trouvé qu'il y avait très peu d'articles à ce sujet.
Certains articles allaient jusqu'à dire que le tissu du muscle squelettique
est résistant au cancer, et, d'ailleurs, pas seulement au cancer,
mais également aux métastases.
Les métastases sont des parties de la tumeur initiale
qui se détachent et voyagent via le courant sanguin pour
s'implanter dans un autre organe. C'est la définition d'une métastase.
Il s'agit de la partie la plus dangereuse du cancer.
Si le cancer est localisé, nous pouvons sûrement l'enlever,
ou du moins, il est limité. C'est un processus très limité.
Mais quand le cancer commence à se déplacer dans le corps, alors il devient mortel.
Donc le fait que non seulement le cancer ne débute pas dans les muscles squelettiques,
mais également qu'il n'y essaime pas,
-- il semblait y avoir quelque chose à explorer.
Ces articles concluaient : "Les métastases au niveau
du muscle squelettique sont très rares."
Mais ils en restaient là. Personne ne semblait se demander pourquoi.
J'ai alors décidé de demander pourquoi. Au départ -- la première chose que j'ai faite --
j'ai envoyé des emails aux professeurs qui
se spécialisaient dans la physiologie du muscle squelettique, et j'ai dit à peu près,
"Hey, apparemment le cancer n'aime pas le muscle squelettique,
y a-t-il une raison à cela ?" Une grande partie des réponses que j'ai reçues,
disaient que le muscle squelettique est un tissu complètement différent.
Cela signifie que les cellules musculaires ne se divisent plus,
et que par conséquent elle ne sont pas une bonne cible pour le cancer.
Mais, encore une fois, le fait que les métastases
ne se localisent pas dans le muscle affaiblissait cette hypothèse.
De plus, le tissu nerveux -- le cerveau -- est une cible fréquente du cancer,
et les cellules du cerveau sont également très différentes.
J'ai donc décidé de demander pourquoi. Et voici certaines de mes hypothèses,
que je vais commencer à étudier en Mai au Sylvester Cancer Institute à Miami.
Et je pense continuer à chercher jusqu'à ce que je trouve des réponses.
Mais je sais qu'en sciences, une fois les réponses obtenues,
de nouvelles questions apparaissent.
Donc je suppose qu'on pourrait imaginer que je chercherai pour le restant de mes jours.
Certaines de mes hypothèses sont que
lorsque vous considérez le muscle squelettique,
il y a de nombreux vaisseaux sanguins qui irriguent le muscle.
Et ma première pensée fut que les vaisseaux
sanguins sont comme des autoroutes pour les cellules cancéreuses.
Les cellules cancéreuses peuvent voyager dans le courant sanguin.
Et donc, le plus d'autoroutes on trouve dans un tissu,
plus il est probable que ce tissu devienne cancéreux ou métastasé.
Au départ, j'ai donc pensé, "Ne serait-ce pas favorable
pour le cancer de se localiser dans le muscle squelettique ?" Et, également,
les tumeurs cancéreuses nécessitent un processus nommé l'angiogénèse,
qui consiste en la tumeur attirant les vaisseaux sanguins à elle afin
de pouvoir s'alimenter pour grandir.
Sans angiogénèse, la tumeur reste de la taille d'une tête d'épingle, inoffensive.
L'angiogénèse est donc un processus central dans la pathogénèse du cancer.
Et un article qui a retenu mon attention, alors que
je lisais sur ce sujet, en essayant de comprendre pourquoi le cancer ne va pas
dans le muscle squelettique, rapportait 16% de micro-métastases dans
le muscle squelettique lors de l'autopsie.
16% ! Ce qui signifiait qu'il y avait ces tumeurs de la taille d'une aiguille dans le muscle squelettique
mais seulement 0,16% de métastases avérées --
ce qui suggérait la capacité du muscle squelettique à contrôler l'angiogénèse,
à contrôler les tumeurs qui captent à elles les vaisseaux sanguins.
Nous utilisons en permanences nos muscles. C'est la seule portion de notre corps
-- notre cœur bat sans arrêt. Nous bougeons tout le temps nos muscles.
Est-ce possible qu'intuitivement le muscle sache qu'il
a besoin de cet afflux sanguin ? Il a besoin de se contracter en permanence,
donc c'est un organe égoïste. Il accapare les vaisseaux sanguins pour son usage.
D'où, lorsqu'une tumeur s'installe dans le muscle squelettique,
elle ne peut s'approvisionner en sang, et ne peut grandir.
Cela suggère qu'il existe peut-être un facteur anti-angiogénique dans
le muscle squelettique -- ou peut-être encore mieux,
un facteur de redirection de l'angiogénèse, qui peut diriger la croissance des vaisseaux sanguins.
Cela pourrait être une thérapie potentielle pour le cancer.
Une autre chose passionnante est qu'il y a cet
ensemble -- la façon dont les tumeurs se déplacent dans le corps par
un système très complexe -- qu'on appelle le réseau de chémokines.
Les chémokines sont essentiellement des capteurs chimiques,
et ce sont les signaux de départ et d'arrêt pour le cancer.
Une tumeur doit donc produire des récepteurs de chémokines,
et un autre organe -- distant dans le corps --
aura les chémokines correspondantes,
et la tumeur va identifier ces chémokines et migrer dans leur direction.
Est-il possible que le muscle squelettique ne produise pas ces types de molécules ?
Et l'autre phénomène vraiment intéressant est que
lorsque le muscle squelettique -- il y a eu plusieurs cas rapportés de corrélation
entre lésion musculaire et développement de métastases musculaires.
De plus, lorsque le muscle squelettique est endommagé,
c'est ce qui est à l'origine des chémokines -- ces signaux qui disent,
"Cancer, tu peux venir à moi", c'est le signal de départ pour les tumeurs
-- ces lésions musculaires sont à l'origine de la production élevée de chémokines.
Il y a beaucoup d'interactions dans ce processus.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il y a tellement de possibilités
pour expliquer l'absence de tumeurs dans le muscle squelettique.
Mais il semble qu'en enquêtant, en attaquant le cancer,
en cherchant pourquoi le cancer n'est pas là, il doit y avoir une raison
-- il doit y avoir quelque chose -- qui rend ce tissu résistant aux tumeurs.
Et pouvons nous utiliser -- pouvons nous prendre cette propriété,
ce composé, ce récepteur, quel que soit ce qui contrôle ces propriétés
anti-tumorales et l'appliquer à la thérapie anti-cancéreuse en général ?
Maintenant, une chose relie un peu la résistance du muscle squelettique au cancer
-- au cancer comme processus de réparation du corps qui échappe au contrôle --
est la présence d'un facteur appelé MyoD dans le muscle squelettique.
MyoD est responsable de la différenciation des cellules
en cellules musculaires. Donc cette protéine, MyoD,
a été testée sur de nombreux autres types cellulaires et il a été montré qu'elle
peut convertir une grande variété de cellules en cellules de muscle strié.
Donc, serait-il possible que les cellules tumorales aillent dans le tissu musculaire,
mais une fois en contact avec ce dernier,
que MyoD agisse sur ces cellules tumorales
pour les transformer en cellules de muscle strié ?
Peut-être que les cellules tumorales sont déguisées en cellules de muscle strié,
et que c'est pour cette raison qu'elle semblent si rares.
Ce n'est pas dangereux, juste une réparation du muscle.
Les muscle sont constamment utilisés, constamment endommagés.
Si, à chaque élongation, à chaque claquage,
ou à chaque faux mouvement,
le cancer se manifestait -- tout le monde aurait le cancer, ou presque.
Et je n'aime pas dire ça. Mais il semble que les cellules musculaires,
peut-être à cause de cette utilisation intensive, se sont adaptées
plus vite que d'autres tissus du corps pour répondre aux lésions,
et pour parfaire ce processus de réparation qui peut alors être effectivement
terminé comme il était initialement prévu. Je crois vraiment que le corps humain est
très, très intelligent et que nous ne pouvons contrecarrer ce que le corps entreprend.
C'est différent lorsqu'une bactérie s'installe dans notre corps,
il s'agit d'un corps étranger -- le corps veut s'en débarrasser.
Mais lorsque le corps est en train d'initier un processus
et que nous l'appelons maladie, il ne me semble pas que l'élimination
soit la bonne solution. Pour aller plus loin, il est possible -- perspective lointaine certes --
que dans le futur nous puissions considérer le cancer comme une thérapie.
Si ces maladies où les tissus dégénèrent
-- par exemple la maladie d'Alzheimer, où le cerveau, les neurones, meurent
et que nous devons recréer des neurones fonctionnels --
peut-être pourrons nous, dans le futur, utiliser le cancer ? Une tumeur
pourrait-elle être implantée dans le cerveau pour regénérer des neurones ?
C'est une idée qui peut sembler tirée par les cheveux, mais je la crois possible.
Ces cellules sont si polyvalentes, ces cellules cancéreuses sont si versatiles
-- nous n'avons qu'à les manipuler correctement.
Et, de nouveau, certaines idées que j'ai exposées peuvent sembler farfelues, mais
je me suis dit que s'il y avait un endroit où les présenter, c'était ici, à TED,
donc merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)